however many of you have felt it itchy
eyes and sneezing
allergy seizing is here and it's causing
many folks a big
deal of discomfort christian casares is
joining us in studio with some tips from
a medical expert on how to avoid
this headache and truly enjoy the day
because i'm telling you christian
me and uh mulberry just not friends at
all
all right well ted let me tell you it's
happening to many of us while we're out
for our morning run running errands or
just
simply hanging out outside with our pets
the itchy and watery eyes
are a grim reminder that allergy season
is here now the severity of the season
depends on the weather
how much rain and wind we get according
to one local doctor
is what drives things but people are
already complaining about feeling those
symptoms
according to dr rich vinuya allergy
symptoms include watery itchy eyes
stuffy nose
congestion and sneezing among others in
the midst
of the pandemic these symptoms could be
mistaken for covet very easy
his advice is to keep a close eye on
your health and don't
ignore it there are
a few ways to distinguish between the
two
usually when you have an infection a
viral infection like colgate
your typical allergy symptoms especially
during the season of allergies will be
much more pronounced
also one of the biggest factors is the
presence of fever
fever is not usually associated with
allergies unless you have a sinus
infection
although allergies are not contagious he
says there are things you can do to help
now try to avoid morning outings because
that's when he says pollen is at its
peak also get an
allergy test to see what you could be
reacting to now dr venueya says having
allergies
does not increase your chances of
getting coveted on the other hand
avoiding medical attention for your
allergies
could cause more problems that could
affect your daily performance
christian casadas 8 news now